[Musica]
la tecnologia può sostituire la presenza
dei docenti a scuola
e quanto internet e i social network
possono cambiare il modello tradizionale
di apprendimento e di insegnamento per
rispondere a queste domande vi
racconterò una storia è una storia vera
iniziata sei anni fa è la storia di un
corso in cui per la prima volta facebook
è stato usato a supporto di alcune
lezioni universitarie
vi dirò delle norme energia che si è
sprigionata in classe e online
e poi vi racconterò di un'indagine più
rigorosa in cui abbiamo cercato di
capire scientificamente se questo
esperimento avesse avuto degli effetti e
infine vorrei condividere con voi alcune
considerazioni sull'uso della tecnologia
nella scuola e chiedermi se si possa
fare a meno dei docenti sono un
matematico e mi piace fare didattica
cerco di convincere i miei studenti con
l'uso dei computer che la matematica può
illuminare la loro vita con applicazione
di avanti e con la sua immortale
bellezza esattamente sei anni fa entrò
in una classe con 400 persone 400 sono
tante sono più di voi tutti qui
all'accademico è impossibile vederli in
faccia erano troppi
a dir la verità ero anche infuriato col
mio ateneo che mi metteva nelle
condizioni di insegnare in questo modo
come si fa a capire se hanno capito come
puoi conoscerli seguirli guidarli e mi
son detto che serviva uno scatto un
supplemento d'anima serviva di fatto un
modo per comunicare con questi studenti
i miei studenti e pensai che per una
volta facebook
poteva essere un modo per dare delle
risposte e ricevere delle domande non
era semplice perché tradizionalmente
facebook è legato alla sfera personale e
raramente ci pensiamo come a uno
strumento che possa essere utilizzato
sul posto di lavoro o di studio
però dovevo fare di necessità virtù e
dovevo trovare e possibilmente
sperimentare un modo nuovo per fare
lezione e quindi costruì la pagina che
vedete alle mie spalle
si chiama mathematics dopo un primo
periodo di cautela alcuni studenti
portarono qualcosa io risposi subito
continuando peraltro ad esaltarli in
classe a utilizzare internet più che
potevano per rendere sensato un corso
così affollato i post lentamente
aumentarono e io ho subito sotto con le
risposte i like he contro l'aj che la
matematica accettavo amicizie via via
questo vivolo di posta diventò un
torrente e poi un fiume e infine
un'inondazione
mia moglie mi disse solo sei fuori di
testa non puoi stare su facebook tutto
il giorno e e a questo punto
a questo punto mi resi conto che mi resi
conto che non ce l'avrei mai potuta fare
a rispondere a tutte queste persone da
solo ma successero delle cose belle
gli studenti iniziarono a rispondersi
fra di loro e poi vennero il mio aiuto
due studentesse speciali la loro
dedizione loro impegno furono
fondamentali
ricordo ancora alessandra che si
materializzò come un personaggio dei
manga giapponesi che ama tanto e rispose
letteralmente a centinaia di domande in
maniera secca precisa puntuale asciutta
ci fu anche marina che aveva uno stile
diverso più empatico e filosofico e
riusciva a condire di ironia alle
risposte di matematica a un certo punto
tutti gli studenti si resero conto che
stava succedendo qualcosa di speciale di
noi parla un blog definendoci una tribù
e e subito dopo
finimmo sul corriere del veneto e infine
sul gazzettino
in questo delirio di post di laica di
matematica ed i mass media
gli studenti erano gasatissimi
e pensarono che questo esperimento
avrebbe fruttato loro fino a tre punti
in più nel voto finale a dir la verità
ero gasato anch'io nel mio piccolo
consentitemelo pensavo di aver fatto la
storia ma ora fermiamoci un attimo
perché è passata l'euforia del momento
mi chiese che cosa fosse successo
intendo che cosa fosse successo
veramente da scienziato so che è
difficile provare l'esistenza di cause e
gli effetti vi faccio un esempio
prendete un gruppo di persone con
l'influenza e date loro un bicchiere di
acqua fresca alla mattina un bicchiere
di acqua fresca alla sera dopo una
settimana
all'incirca metà di loro sarà guarito
potete concludere che l'acqua fresca
cura l'influenza ovviamente no sappiamo
che che non è così e metà di quelle
persone probabilmente sarebbe guarita in
ogni caso conoscenza acquafresca
allo stesso modo come potevo essere
sicuro che facebook era stato ben etico
per i miei studenti magari erano bravi
di suo
magari noi docenti eravamo stati larghi
di manica quei voti
magari semplicemente l'aria di treviso è
più buona di quella di venezia
come si fa a capire se una cosa ha
effetti nella scienza si usa un gruppo
di controllo
ma noi non ce l'avevamo e allora
decidemmo di crearselo per confrontare
in maniera rigorosa le performance degli
studenti di facebook con quelle degli
studenti di analoghi corsi senza
facebook e per quattro anni abbiamo
raccolto dati aspettando ad esempio che
questi studenti si laurea se lo per
poter escludere che si trattasse di un
gruppo di qualità straordinaria
pensate che abbiamo perfino esaminato la
qualità di tutte le scuole superiori da
cui provenivano
anche in questa fase è una persona
eccezionale mi è stata d'aiuto gira a
quel tempo era una dottoranda in bocconi
e lei con me per mesi ha scandagliato
matricole e setacciato dati per cercare
di capire se c'erano delle differenze
fra quelli di facebook e gli altri
eravamo entrati in quella modalità che
io chiamo caccia ad ottobre rosso
forse vi ricordate il film in cui il
capitano di un sottomarino russo che
sean connery si immerge negli abissi per
sfuggire agli americani
allo stesso modo noi cercavamo di capire
se facebook aveva avuto degli effetti ma
facebook si stava nascondendo e si era
immerso in un oceano di potenziali altre
spiegazioni e controllo dopo controllo
limatura dopo limatura l'effetto netto
di facebook scendeva e passò da tre
punti a 2 e poi a 10 75 e alla fine
mezzo punto ecco siamo all'epilogo di
questa storia
quanto vale facebook dal punto di vista
didattico intendo quanto vale dopo che
hai lavato via il divertimento l'euforia
e hai tenuto conto della bravura
intrinseca degli studenti della qualità
del loro diploma superiore del
contributo di noi docenti
quanto vale beh mezzo punto è tanto è
poco questo lo lascio decidere a voi
ma fatemi dire che a me pare poco e so
perfettamente che bisogna lavorare duro
per ottenere dei piccoli miglioramenti
questo appunto a me pare un piccolo
miglioramento mezzo trentesimo anche se
va spalmato su una platea di 400 persone
e se ci pensate forse questo è anche
ragionevole forse eravamo matti a
pensare che facebook avrebbe cambiato il
modo di imparare
forse era ovvio che non ci sono
scorciatoie che studiare costa fatica
che devi passare le ore sui libri che le
sudate carte non te le toglie nessuno
forse è ovvio ci hai bisogno di una
persona in gamba di un docente in gamba
che ti guarda negli occhi capisce dal
tuo sguardo se hai capito e se deve
dispiegare forse eravamo semplicemente
ingenui a pensare che saremmo diventati
di colpo dei geni a colpi di post ed i
like e allora
pensiamoci la prossima volta che
all'ennesima riforma della scuola
la discussione si focalizza troppo solo
sulla
tecnologia sulle lavagne interattive
sulle lim sugli ipad e sugli smartphones
forse c'è bisogno di insegnanti in gamba
impegno e buone strutture e internet
si si come abbiamo visto internet è
utile
cidiverte diverte siano gli adulti che
voi tutti nativi digitali ma a conti
fatti alla fine della fiera
le persone sono importanti e internet
vale solo mezzo punto
grazie
[Applauso]